The year 2020 brings with it a host of new
TV options, from broadcast thrillers to Disney
Plus franchises, and a great many of them
are set to scratch your science fiction itch.
Whether you're watching traditional TV or
binge watching your heart out on your favorite
streaming service, here are the sci-fi shows
to watch out for in 2020.
Snowpiercer took a long journey on its way
to a television debut, and it was almost as
wild and dramatic behind the scenes as the
story being told on the show.
The series is based on the 2013 film of the
same name, directed by Academy Award winner
Bong Joon-ho and starring Chris Evans and
Tilda Swinton, which was itself adapted from
the French graphic novel that debuted in 1982.
The TV development saga, meanwhile, dates
all the way back to 2015.
In the time since, the series has seen its
original showrunner exit, its original pilot
director refuse to come back for reshoots,
and had its network changed from TNT to TBS
and then back to TNT.
It's been a long ride, but now, Snowpiercer
is finally ready to depart on its television
voyage.
The Snowpiercer series is, like the film and
graphic novel, set several years after the
world has been enveloped in ice and rendered
uninhabitable.
Viewers will follow the residents of a massive
locomotive as it circles the snowbound world,
with the focus on the various class struggles
and schemes within the crude society that's
sprung up among the remnants of humanity.
Starring Hamilton's Daveed Diggs and Oscar
winner Jennifer Connelly, Snowpiercer will
finally debut on TNT on May 31, 2020.
For the last eight years, Dark Horse Comics
has been home to Peter Hogan and Steve Parkhouse's
Resident Alien.
The comic book series centers on an alien
from outer space who's forced to hide out
in a small town while he waits for someone
from his species to come and pick him up.
Since 2018, SYFY has been developing a TV
series based on the comics, and in 2020 we'll
finally get to see the fruits of that labor.
Resident Alien stars Alan Tudyk as the title
alien, who adopts the human name Harry Vanderspiegle.
After finding himself stranded on Earth, Harry
decides to take on a human disguise and pose
as a doctor in a small Colorado town.
That's all complicated enough, but life gets
a little harder for Harry when he's roped
into a series of mysteries he must help to
solve.
Oh, and there's one kid in the town who can
see right through his human disguise.
Resident Alien will premiere on SYFY in the
summer of 2020.
The vast collection of shows and characters
known to fans as the Arrowverse just keeps
expanding over at the CW. 2020 sees the flagship
series that launched the small-screen universe,
Arrow, ending its run after the death of Oliver
Queen in the "Crisis on Infinite Earths" crossover,
but that just means there's more room in the
schedule for future series.
Thankfully for fans who've been eager to see
more of them, some of that room is going to
be taken up by the Arrowverse's all-new Superman
and Lois Lane.
The most prevalent version of Superman in
this universe, played by Tyler Hoechlin, first
popped up on Supergirl, while his version
of Lois Lane, played by Elizabeth Tulloch,
debuted in the "Elseworlds" crossover event
in December of 2018.
In October of 2019, the CW announced that
it was developing a spinoff series that would
center on Hoechlin's Superman and Tulloch's
Lois, fulfilling a longstanding fan wish for
a new TV series about the Couple of Steel.
Superman & Lois does not yet have a premiere
date, but we'll likely see it arriving sometime
in the fall of 2020.
Steve Carell became a global superstar thanks
to his starring role in The Office, a workplace
comedy series that led to numerous opportunities
as a film actor in both comedy and drama.
In 2020, Carell is returning to the workplace,
and he's bringing Office writer Greg Daniels
along for the ride.
Space Force, co-created by Carell and Daniels,
will follow a group of government employees
as they try to develop the sixth branch of
the United States Armed Forces.
Carell will play a general trying to lead
the Space Force in its mission to get back
to the moon by 2024.
Carell is joined on the mission by an incredible
ensemble cast, including The Americans' Noah
Emmerich, Sonic the Hedgehog's Ben Schwartz,
and John Malkovich, another actor who's brilliant
at both comedy and drama.
With Carell starring as well as co-creating
the series, we can expect plenty of Office-level
gags along the way when Space Force hits Netflix
in 2020.
In the spring of 2019, Avengers: Endgame ended
a decade-long era of storytelling in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with a climactic battle
for the fate of all existence.
It also set the stage for the next phase of
stories in the MCU.
We're only just beginning to see what comes
next, but we do know a lot of it will unfold
on the Disney Plus streaming service, through
shows like The Falcon and the Winter Soldier.
At the end of Endgame, Steve Rogers passed
Captain America's shield on to his friend
Sam Wilson, better known as Falcon, with the
blessing of Steve's best friend Bucky Barnes,
a.k.a. the Winter Soldier.
The upcoming Disney series will explore the
aftermath of that decision, as Sam contends
with the legacy he's now a part of with a
little help from Bucky.
The series will also feature the return of
Helmut Zemo from Captain America: Civil War
and Sharon Carter to the MCU, as well as the
live-action debut of Captain America knockoff
U.S. Agent.
The Falcon and the Winter Soldier will arrive
on D+ sometime in late 2020.
The events of Avengers: Infinity War and Avengers:
Endgame also had a major impact on the lives
of Vision and Scarlet Witch.
The battle with Thanos left Vision apparently
dead and his lover mourning him, but the pair
are set to be reunited in WandaVision, a new
Disney Plus series that will somehow trap
the two heroes in a condensed history of television
sitcoms.
Exactly how and why that happens is the mystery
that we're left with after the teaser, but
we do know that a few familiar faces will
be back in action for the show.
Teyonah Parris has joined the series as an
adult version of Monica Rambeau, the longtime
comic book hero who first appeared as a child
in Captain Marvel.
The series will also re-introduce Thor supporting
character Darcy Lewis, played by Kat Dennings,
to the MCU when it hits Disney Plus some time
in 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.